dangerous weather targeting more than 30
million Americans a fast-moving storm is
already being blamed for at least three
deaths in Louisiana
an elderly man was killed when a tree
fell onto his home early Saturday
morning toppled trees and snapped power
lines are scattered all across the
northwest part of the state
the storm system has dropped heavy rain
and win across Texas Oklahoma Louisiana
Missouri and Arkansas tornadoes have
been reported in at least three states
and in Iowa snow plows are out in what
is that area's first major winter storm
of the season the snowfall is heavy
having already caused several traffic
accidents hundreds of flights have also
been cancelled
Omar Villafranca is in Kilgore Texas
with more on the storm Omar good morning
good morning those overnight storms
packed quite a punch and people here in
East Texas are getting a first-hand look
at the damage this morning we're
surrounded by sheep metal and a bunch of
insulation come to find out it came from
this building way over here matter of
fact part of the roof is missing all
caused by the powerful winds from last
night's storm parts of Stratford
Missouri have been reduced to rubble and
residents are tarping their rooms to
prepare for more dangerous weather a
tornado touched down near this trailer
park tarring roofs off of several
buildings tractor trailers at this truck
stop were flipped onto their sides
similar conditions tore through Texas
where strong winds and heavy rainfall
flooded streets and caused traffic
accidents from San Antonio to Irving
powerful winds blew over part of this
houston gas station and firefighters say
a lightning bolt seared the side of this
home in San Antonio in Oklahoma
emergency crews were called to several
homes destroyed by the wind got the
generators gassed up just in case
residents in Central Michigan are buying
up emergency supplies ahead of an ice
storm emergency items flashlights
batteries things of this nature the Iowa
State Patrol says it has responded to
more than 100 calls during the winter
storm
so far and it could get worse as road
conditions continue to deteriorate
counties in eastern Kansas are expecting
snowfall totals up to five inches that
snowfall will create additional hazards
for parts of the state already drenched
by frozen rain you're not going to be
able to see the ice on the roads and
that's just so dangerous people in
Louisiana Mississippi and Alabama need
to keep an eye on the weather today the
big threats they're possible tornadoes
and strong winds and Michelle I know you
have family in Louisiana it's going
through there right now as we speak
my goodness we'll keep those eyes open
Omar thank you
meteorologist Jeff Barry Daly has more
on the nation's weather and that keen
eye we were talking about Jeff good
morning good morning Michelle and good
morning everybody and yes there is a
very serious line of thunderstorms
moving through the southeast right now
right along the Mississippi River and
the reason why it's so strong we have an
incredibly strong low level jet stream
with winds over 100 miles an hour and
some of that wind could be tapped and
brought to the ground in wing Gus 5
tornado watch boxes now in the south and
a little bit of snow that'll become more
snow later today up north we have a
tremendous contrast in temperatures
across the United States it's 75 in
Louisiana right now negative 30 in
northern Michigan with that sharp 105
temperature contrast and a very strong
upper level jet stream winds 250 miles
an hour combining forces with a low
level jet stream right now with winds of
a hundred miles an hour notice the winds
coming in from different directions that
can spin these storms and cause tornado
so watch out for tornadoes and very
strong wind gusts this is the Future
radar today
heaviest rain moves through Nashville
and Birmingham this afternoon as we head
into the evening hours watch out Chicago
for flight delays heavy snow will be
moving through Atlanta strong line of
thunderstorms in tomorrow morning New
York severe weather as possible we're
gonna see 300 record highs and lows
possible this weekend guys you have to
do 75 in Louisiana right now and yet 30
below 30 below it is northern Michigan
it's incredibly warm in the East again
300 Records 30 to 40 degrees above
normal this weekend in the east
well alright Jeff Burton Ellie thank you
very much
you